so today I want to give you a tip on a
very effective remedy for toenail fungus
and it's epson salts epson salts is a
naturally occurring mineral salt
magnesium sulfate which has some pretty
good antimicrobial and antifungal
properties here's what you do
you take two tablespoons of epsom salts
and you dissolve it in four cups of
water you can bring it to a boil you
don't have to the main thing is getting
it dissolved and keeping it nice and
warm wait till close down a little bit
and then put your foot in a little
bucket okay and soak it for 15 minutes
every single day for about three to four
weeks and you'll see a great improvement
also use a nail file to get rid of some
of the dead nail because the problem is
this fungus tends to get up underneath
the nail and destroys the nails but you
might find depending on how infected the
nail is that the nail may have to come
off and regrow or if the infection is
not too deep the nail will just kind of
come back without this microbe that's
invading it the other thing to do is to
avoid moisture because this microbe
likes a humid environment so go to work
without your shoes don't mention my name
when you do that and this will help
alright guys thanks for watching if
you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos